all right if we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 87 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got our big XO 2018
panel break down the dominance of PS now
and the future of square-enix to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord was not
only one of the most passionate members
in our entire gaming community but also
one of the most detailed reviewers in
the game although this Lord make
different opinion with some one specific
game topics his infectious positivity
will always win you over in it
introducing the creator of the gene
cascais youtube channel and panelists of
the spawn cast the Lord we always count
on a tell us of a questionable game
actually sucks or buzzes - keep dreaming
making his return into the realm of the
Lord's mommy Lord Dreamcast guy I happy
to be here this is my third time on may
4th time on and every time it's a blast
seriously thank you so much for having
me back so so much man so many good
games so many bad games and playing that
this week I'm playing a bunch of fallout
76 in battlefield 5 and both them are
very different than I thought they were
gonna be mmm interesting bill don't file
your reviews her up they gotta be going
up soon I know you got a lot of things
cooking yeah yeah those should be out
Tuesday and Wednesday I think they're
gonna be on the next couple days man I
played I played a lot of them man the
business glad to have you back there and
of course we have a lord who is no
stranger to the round table and with the
mere mention of his name
you automatically makes synonymous with
the xbox pray this Lord continued
meteoric rise has truly been a sight to
behold yet at the same time will always
be considered a true friend to the ILP
introducing the creator and host of the
planet xbox podcast a member of the
weapon wheel podcast by far the best bot
in these Xbox treats and the fearless
Lord who was always willing to put his
convictions to the test in any last
dream or debate also making his return
into the realm of the Lord's my lord
kids smoke I'm just going to repeat the
last intro thanks for having me back
we're perfect day you know just EXO 18
just wrapped up and you know I'm already
you know you know having a lot of
conversations on Twitter here and there
so yes it's time to be on so appreciate
the invite absolutely Britta while I
look man you have a bitter little while
I gotta hack back so I know the EXO
emotions of fresh never get some good
commentary from you at Dreamcast guy I
have a high breakdown know we got the
Four Horsemen of gaming those usual
suspects at the round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother
the difficult game chakra and the half
of the young mommy
doing pretty good here exclusively to
make King you was not playing Red Dead
Redemption - no actually I didn't drop
it but like I gotta drop it did you
reach out under your bed and grab the
bottle of Red Bull and rip it
before I get is a process not a lot of
hottest you get back into it yeah I
really enjoy I really think it's my game
of the year we have almost technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also Sasha Adonis
mr. offline profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon of the iron bank mommy
lord I need too much too much Mme too
much red dead oh yeah that's what I've
read that red dead recap for the week
I've been a very bad
sorry da just busted in one sec sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my honour is in the toilet right now I
found a little exploit for making money
kind of quick
there's no you take you stayed six
stagecoaches two and up so he's going
about that on youtube right now yeah
it's
what's worse using a glitch for money or
using auto assist it's not a glitch
though it's just me murdering everybody
inside that's what so basically the
defense that you take take all of your
listed items too you also get you also
take stagecoaches right so where he's
located is like a bar unlike an in an
open plain area so there's a lot of
stage coaches they go through there so I
just hang out in the area a short trip
to deliver them and get my $40 Wow
building money up that way right the
juice is real the game once the game
realizes what you're doing and pushes
back on you and it's like okay so as
soon as you murder somebody somebody
will mysteriously appear round the bend
to be a witness and then you've got a
you know the whole domino frame you
gotta kill them or intimidate them or
whatever and then before you know it you
have like and then the second thing is I
strolled upon this place called Aberdeen
pig farm right in this place and then a
cutscene sort of ensued this is one
again one of those side missions in the
open world so as I walk up to the house
the biggest overall wearing Bigfoot
cousin Buford looking
uncle Cletus he's like come on in friend
yeah but he wanted me he was so happy to
see me then a woman comes out it appears
to be his wife and he turns out neither
wife is a sister but they're very
lovey-dovey with each other and with me
like really want me to join them so I'm
like ah big is going down although they
invite me in for dinner right you know
this is the thing it actually doesn't
turn out as I thought I said let me
watch this play out I want to see what
these crazy people not do so he tells me
some real statistic stuff you did it's
not like deliverance laughs yeah you you
went on there because you Loki wanted to
kill these people what they wanted to do
so he tells me she's taking a long time
to come down for dinner why don't you go
up and get her I'm like this is your
he's no no she likes it when people go
up and watch me knows before I go see
her I start snooping around the house
open up a cabinet and I see Skull and
Bones and get her and she's like oh
she's like oh I'll be down in a sec I
know you like to watch me there's that
any other so I go back down and she
comes down afterwards he serves dinner
and I don't know what the hell's you
serve for dinner
right he said it's interesting I don't
know what this is but so then they offer
me a drink and it's like some absinthe
drink and they're like you drink it and
they give you the option to keep
drinking or not so I'm no drink I'm
gonna be I wanna see where this goes
well you're burly goes so I blackout
right and then when I come to I they
just they just basically robbed me and
threw me out in a ditch in the rain with
other bodies that they've apparently
robbed or whatever so it wasn't I
thought it was gonna be some freaky S&M
stuff
just said game over screen and there was
just a bunch of skeletons around mailman
oh I woke up back to the house and
proceeded to blow their heads off and
that was that that was my Red Dead recap
for the week we won't stop calling it
red they're with you they'll call it
murder simulation you want me to come
back around yeah we'll come back around
look I'll give it back
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the XS gamer oh the
lord of combat sports who was a man of
his convictions demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement I'm
gonna take that game I'm gonna put me
meat hooks inside of it and happy if you
didn't get your little dollars together
and rub them nickels together make magic
and get yourself God or all King is
about to blow it up for you check this
out you guys in my timeline told me
spider-man Oh first of all this is
what I don't like about you PlayStation
dudes and weirdos let me tell you
something no this is this is the truth
yes that he always running around with
God of War running around with these
little flags it's true I got that game
and I was like ok now I'm down with that
smite amount of smoke ok
the spider-man see what I say you're
kidding but your bias means really was
never but that got a walk
no I wasn't but I said I'm gonna give it
a chance right I brought it first
and it was putting me to sleep when I
was playing it I said man they looked at
Gears of War they said we gonna copy the
same exact formula going the side of
room block it off clear off that room
and move to the next room I said this
just this is not this is not my thing
but then later on in the game I gotta
give it credit it made it better it did
and it introduced something to the game
that made the game more exciting and fun
for me cuz I write you attacking me
doing with you like yo your [ __ ] is
heating up I'm starting to get into it
ok my problem is with Kelvin and the
script the budget over exceeded actual
you know bosses okay you fight that
mysterious do first in the beginning
he's a mysterious dude the second time
you fight him he's not mysterious cuz
you know he's the last time you fight
him he's really not mysterious because
you know who he is and you know his
storyline what this guy three times you
know fourth to over in five hundred
different colors that's a dick problem
I got a defend added people dragged
Attic for weeks when he was playing and
he was doing his live impression he was
like look the game is great but what's
up with these trolls every I got a
different flavor truck yeah they're like
you gotta go you gotta go to hell and
get this or man like that's the only way
you could save them you gotta go to hell
and get this orb alright we're about to
have some crazy fight get there it's a
purple troll troll fest right I mean
because I did the 88 Roll Marathon oh
right okay so we found Valkyries in the
world what I don't like about God war is
this right there's so much content in
that world the end game to them this is
what they said right the end game is two
worlds that you can't get those other
worlds that you really can't get to
right but it's two worlds that you can't
get to know you come on issues twos I
felt like shouldn't put stuff in a game
you literally can't get to thank you
thank you you sat there breaking your
head trying to figure out how can I get
to Asgard but it's right here on the
board disc what we're gonna do is show
you something that you can never attain
like you know in spider-man if you see
the bridge you can get to the bridge how
about that I'm going over there the game
is set up as a giant DLC and the end
game you go into this world and you form
this mist dust by going into this
average changing world it's like a maze
but it's never the same it's randomly
generated right and this is what they're
trying to say how to keep you coming
back to get different gear right story
is dead there's nothing else for you to
do but keep going to these randomly
generated mazes which are boring as hell
fighting the same enemies with nothing
else really to do or you could go to the
little fireplace and have endless
enemies attack you he's not lying the
ink game is kind of bad it's terrible
now let's not be fun thing about the
game mm-hmm let's get to the last part
of the story because I dragged this a
little bit too long let's go that's
continue your slander let's get to the
end this whole game was about me taking
the ashes of my wife back to home in
this scattering let's go
I struggled and I built up and I thought
I was gonna get these epic fights with
these gods that's god of war right he is
the God of War right he fought one God
he went to war with one God the whole
damn game and the two gods that they
teased throughout the whole game you
don't see unless you by chance decide to
go back to your cabin in the back so I
got to the mountain I spread the ashes
so I get it's about to be on the fight
of the century
I am here the credits start rolling this
damn game I said did this damn game just
do that to me did I this is my $60 here
this is my $60 ok coming from spider-man
where is a real ending real middle and
real bosses will everything I'm really
I'm shortchanged here brother magneto
said yo you gotta go to cabin OH
I said yo I could not wait to get back
to the cabin boy lay down let's have
some sleep
separate beds not together right
it says the cutscene pops up and says
few years later mm-hmm
they get out with the same exact clothes
lightning is going on outside hmm
you girls die you said yes I'm going to
fight focus you know it's Thor he stands
there he pulls back his cape
Oh the hermanas in the and I said they
wake up from a dream because it was a
dream sequence and I said father I just
had a dream Thor came here to kick our
butts it's like yeah he said oh no it
was the future if it was the past but it
seemed real to me I said yeah it was
really messed up that they teased you
and you didn't get a chance to get a
real good ending the game cannot be game
of the year it's a very good game but
it's in the bushes in spider-man Wow of
course he's an Xbox person what could
you expect for the Xbox greatest games
that grow great points right he made the
points that everybody's afraid to make a
bow got a we're not saw both got it were
inspired man we're great games but deer
for deer flaws were severely overlooked
like nothing about they're better than
Red Dead if any other game right had the
same flaws of spider-man and got a war
they will be highlights of first [ __ ]
people get to talk about but because it
was God Warren spider-man near exclusive
nobody's like no it was it was a padding
like no no no well because it is well
because of that well yeah but it did
this it's like but he's right because I
remember being in a party chat we're
attic and we're sitting there and I rest
like I who's gonna beat this game first
and I'm like attic I think you notice
these damn boss fights I don't know if
they're meant to be boss fight but
there's a lot of [ __ ] trolls in this
game they finally mix it up oh you
witness when you get that you know sorry
for the spoiler you get the blades and
[ __ ] ok we already turned yeah well
still the [ __ ] troll what I mean I
mean I enjoyed God worries that it was a
game of the Year contender on me but I
mean I feel like there was a lot of
great games that came out this year but
guy so he dropped at the baby sling so
my thing is so god of war is probably my
game of the year but the thing is I'm
coming from the direction of I hated the
other games actually and I know I'm very
alone in that but I thought that the
other games were just so
mindless and nashi it was just about
going in there and ripping people apart
so like blindly I like that this game
was so much slower my only complaint
about the game wasn't even the
repetitive bosses it was that I thought
the story was fantastic I did think that
a lot of the fights though became very
very rhythmic in nature and that became
boring to me like you really do get to
whip you get your two main weapons
basically nature couple spells but once
you find a system that works like okay
here's the ice spikes that we're good
for me that's all you're ever going to
use and I hate I hate games that allow
you to be lazy in a fight I feel like
every fight should push you to your
limits you know they only really
challenge you into Valkyrie fights goes
back yeah yeah exactly all of your
skills like let me actually one question
being that you hated all the dogs of war
yeah yeah I just um my question is and
this is my only gripe with it right
mm-hmm
how did you fight Boulder the whole game
like he's the main antagonist the whole
game
no God of War before that gyro anytime
cuz they'd released other ones after it
- no God of War has ever lets you just
fight one god and call it a day I mean
you fought Thor's two children those are
little side bosses and that was nice but
major you're talking about you opened up
with the Kraken you fought Hades you for
Poseidon before Zeus you fought Hercules
you did all these things in these
previous gods war games
you fought Valkyries and stuff like that
winged uh demons and stuff the diversity
in those games were overbearing to the
part that this feels mundane and lazy to
just have you fight a guy that maybe
some people who don't know Asgardian
Laure don't know who Balder is hmm I
liked that though because it felt like
it finally managed to slow things down
the same way that the way Red Dead
really pulls you in is just by giving
you the entire outback and you just kind
of get free to explore this feels like
I enjoyed this got a war so much more
because there was one bad guy because
there was only a couple trolls because I
had more chances to actually talk to my
weird creepy son who's facing
opportunities I had more chance to
really absorb what the world is you know
the only thing I didn't have an issue of
fighting Boulder I felt like that was a
good way to start the series because if
you remember correctly in the first god
of war you only really fought Ares my
issue was the definitely the trolls I
felt like the ending was a problem too
they should have had us fight Thor and
then you know maybe Odin just like shows
up and makes Thor leave and it was like
well this isn't over and then they came
in yeah at least it would like they
could have let Odin just push it in like
just beat the hell out you know what I
say like you'd do something like that
let like some kind of like remember in
god war 2 how like you're all mouth
powerful and then Zeus just shows up and
shows you what's up yeah boom then the
game ends where it's a good conclusion
you know there's people stronger than
you and you got to come back stronger
yeah God you guys so I watched a bunch
of developer interviews with the
director because I'm so interested in
this game like its development cycle and
stuff and something that Corey balrog
said is the fact that originally they
were gonna have this game be like 60
hours they're gonna have it where you
went through you killed these gods and
then you also took on Thor and then you
ended with Odin and they were working on
all I'm glad they didn't do that
yeah and they thought that they were
like okay honestly this was just gonna
blow up the whole universe like we would
just put everything into one game it
would take 20 years to make and it'd be
great but it's also the time
think of like it would just cost us a
billion dollars so they decided to end
up here because it had a good ending to
that story if you start out chopping
down the tree and burning your wife to a
crisp and then you're taking those
crisps to the top of the Mount I'm out
and I pouring out the Pringles that is
that story and so now it sets it up so
now they can have all the freaking games
they want leading up to murder in the
hell out of we're about to get to you
know at least I play God a war at least
I'm expiring cuz I still let me get to
what I played this week all right let me
get off this fraud police stuff this
week I'm playing God of War this week
all right um after I finished it I saw
some I posted oh wow I was act and
somebody said you really thinking went
someplace which a little level six gives
anybody yo he stole my chest and soul
into the back of my body when he posted
here level nine get he was level nine
here's some armor call Zeus is something
I said brother I bow down I gave him the
knee you I'm going right back into the
bushes and I look like you so I look
like I'm gonna do my push-ups and lift
these weights until I look like mess
with you like before we get off the
subject I think there's one of the
biggest things that really like
captivated me when I come to this game
it was just a pure nostalgia like what I
was going and I knew I got to go get
those blades man I was like yo this is
about to get crazy then would you
actually put them on and then they're
just okay
you had the ax was still my favorite one
because it was more diverse he's like
but we don't give what we're gonna like
do stuff we didn't do when you had the
ax in a city three or four people we sit
because you know that the blades are
designed to what you wanna hear what you
need to insanely busy we have not got a
chance to do too much gaming but I touch
the switch you to see with their YouTube
okay mostly full functionality oh the
only thing I did like I don't think the
resolution is high maybe I don't know
what's going on there but I was
surprised the connections pretty smooth
but the only thing is for YouTube
premium guys I'm using premium so one of
the key features of it is to be able to
download YouTube videos when you don't
have internet access so you can watch
them later and I thought that'd be
perfect for the switch and I put in my
YouTube premium account and there's no
function yeah you know to step forward
step back that I go to the switch Pro
here right before he goes exclusive you
know what I expected I really
did you tell the truth about it when it
comes to this little switch thingy thing
it exists would you have the issues
because all you try to get because I
mean that's the part the actual
connectivity is the strength I was
expecting Wi-Fi connectivity let's see
it probably be shaky a bit buffering I
was rewinding fast-forwarding everything
was cool what didn't have no long buffer
periods any of that so I think their
whole focus was to get it to work and
don't care about the resolution of the
resolution at the end of the day you
know I bought my switch to play you know
buffer that 360p shut up repeat I really
didn't you gotta understand the
hypocrisy with these two individuals
listen listen because I'm gonna tell you
something sovereign you sat there with
your technical behind you
the screen resolution on a switch and
you did not jump into the tool right now
pc rig should be coming about two weeks
get my destiny two or sixty frames I'm
happy about that
drink ask uh what what did you end up
going with with your PC I noticed you
had to get another one
I I'm not even sure a fan actually
enough sending me a fan of mine runs uh
some PC review website and so they send
him all sorts of crazy stuff and so he
he and enseña me arise in oh gosh he's
doing a bunch of stuff this is a very
top-of-the-line PC but it's already I've
been using it to render videos and it's
crazy I have a terrible habit of I grew
up so extremely poor I had this terrible
habit of just using things till they
just explode like I will I will play a
concert until it catches on fire and
stuff which is which is good because it
means I save money but my old PC was so
terrible and I had no idea
I didn't even I was basically rendering
things in a turd max trust me I know the
feeling well I've been doing his
extender for addicts PC die extended
family to somebody need something to
addy
no doubt we were good on we gotta get oh
I'm gonna build a Dreamcast you're wrong
flat wrong so Disney owns the video game
I'm sure so so I heard uh leaks about
five years ago about when they were
first shopping around the spider-man
project and something I heard of the
time is that Sony is trying to concrete
the rights so they owned the digital
version of them forever which will be
both movie rights and video game rights
but never have any control over the
comics and so the way it sounds to me is
the way it was told to me is that Sony
wants spider-man going forward to be the
official mascot of the PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 5 so if they don't legally
owned the rights now I hear to you in
the next year and a half we're gonna see
some weird contract show up thats all of
a sudden where spider-man is a Sony
character that exists in the Marvel
Universe real quick so now we got into
what most plane everybody and I was
being at launch weekend Scott has
already received the Royal Treatment
please check out our Pete them with 37
and drink guys got you have some amazing
video game system its Irie listen to it
oh man the stories were classic you know
Sam but I recently realized Lord smooth
has not been on since I LP 15 so that
was before yes it's really that long bro
yep no he came on after that nobody yeah
we did we did a merger show we did the
Motor Show over there but he hasn't been
in the round since I LP 15 so quickly
going to a brief run lost weight loss
move what got you into gaming was your
video game system history because I
never got that from you oh [ __ ] because
you slipped a couple of times like we
are the preferred listening podcast
Westchester schools what got you into
gang I would say ma'am
my brains so sad um it was a it was a it
was a NES SNES I so I officially my
first console I ever had was a Super
Nintendo and that's until some crazy
chick kicked a hole on the side of it
but the games I've had like I see I
wasn't the type of person that had like
those you know those every game for
every system I kind of had like I
wondered I had like two to three games
up until like I think ps2 came out and
that's when I got to adventure off but
like my mom would give me like their
normal stuff right super need to know
here's super mario land here is Donkey
Kong you know when I was in a situation
there was like NES around they had Super
Mario all-stars so and Mike Tyson's
punch-out so those are the things I like
kind of and that's where actually I got
my raging habits from it was actually my
punch out was when I first like ever had
a rage moment that um my mom was
watching me play a game and she noticed
me screaming and the throwing a
controller and crying and she was like
she was like you shouldn't play that
game anymore because Mickey mad and I
never took the advice because I wanted
to overcome and I think when I finally
play that I was so happy but when I
finally played it the NES couldn't
belong to me be well I think I've heard
where I'll actually say that to you a
couple times yes yes any belong to me
other times but when I beat it right the
next day when I went to go turn it on
the thing didn't turn on anymore I tried
down the disc but ya know those were
like like as far as the early on like
consoles otherwise it was like when I
was able to because I was always a
generation or two behind and I was
always a generation or two behind up
until literally the ps2 and that's the
ps2 and a Nintendo 64 was kind of like
consoles I could claim like a I own and
I actually bought a game for and so a
PlayStation 2 was probably like like the
console that like where I took gaming
serious it wasn't just something I did
after schools like I start to take it
serious in the eyes
sixty I was in a new world cuz I thought
I literally thought 360 was the myspace
for gaming time when myspace was hot you
know
yeah well as Abbas days of poverty so
we're you you missed out on the og on
the OG xbox oh yeah yeah we used to make
decisions based on who had the best
wrestling game dawg like no I had 64 64
in places inside with I well from I went
from Nintendo 64 right to places into
and the reason why I wanted a
PlayStation 2 smoker my best friend had
a smackdown yeah go over there and I
used to just sit there and play
underestimate how much these wrestling
games no mercy but many people react
like oh my god solver tell you man yes
games it would just it brought everybody
together and remember you got to think
about the timing wrestling was such
added to peak that I went over there for
the fighting games and have fun with the
fighting game and they would fold our
fund confidence and doing some sweaty
wrestling know what I gotta bend enjoy
because we're not dealing doing this
they not stop with the goddamn ninety
nine overall Goldberg and away I don't
wanna jump didn't sway they do one thing
right for me by that game I saw a guy
that I idolized and I thought he was
like the greatest wrestler because you
know Cognito had
ultimate warrior and I couldn't think
that that's his dude but then I was like
cuz I'd never saw anybody I really liked
until I saw Goldberg and he walked him
like a hundred a hundred or yo he came
to the ring with police standing with
this giant fantastic belt just just
Buddha's he's a maniac and he sent me he
had FAC like I said I got my wrestler
and it fell he fell in my lap in that
game and I was so pleased that that
happened for me terrorized Bobby did he
kick gloat right there so you're a
wrestler game so you can follow where
the best yeah yeah so first I'd like
during a Nintendo PlayStation 1
generation Nintendo had the best
wrestling games Smackdown no mercy
revenge nothing was touching those um
even though I prefer the the WWF Ridge
because I prefer WWF WCW like it onto me
like I don't know I had something like I
preferred Undertaker and Kane compared
to sting guy prefers don't leave Austin
to build over you know which yeah so
those were it and that would literally
sit there in front of um I remember a
moment I used to have like cuz we used
to wrestle on real life to like make
plastic belts and I will pump in no
mercy or one of them cuz it one of them
played their theme songs longer at least
to go into the creative character
because we would we would apply theme
songs to us more coming out and I used
to have Shawn Michaels HBK song okay we
used to do he would bought he bought the
WCW what is $50 to a LaBelle yeah we
would do two tournaments bro and after
like whoever
one would get to go home because that
was the oh you still got it right so my
best friend at time his name was Tyler
he lived like the suburbs and whatnot
and he would used to do the submission
move to me like that like I would tap
out right yo we got so much trouble
because his his mom was renovating a
basement I used to break the [ __ ] right
so what we used to do we used to go up
and do ladder matches would take like
the notice Phyllis quiz and I sure as
king if he's redid his like living room
like you know the ceiling squares like
that I used to take that and they were
soft right so yeah smack it across each
other's back when we did that yeah I
remember I remember how I know what we
were just taking [ __ ] too far because
one day's his mob came downstairs as she
looked at the ceiling and the roof was
[ __ ] missing she looked at the floor
she was like and I remember and that was
the day you know I won the championship
because I remember I jumped off the pool
table with of the ceiling tile and I
landed on his head not the mount pinned
him and I was able to bring you guys
selling matches are you really not we
would emphasize a little bit like for
example if I pull a moth that didn't
pull off before in black you know
different let you get
she was trying to renovate that house to
us was it so when I went home for the
belt over the first time I'm white and I
lived in like the hood right so all my
friends that the problem was it was
stolen technically because no no no I
hear some [ __ ] up
they enable a 24-hour hardcore match so
when I came home right I got the belt I
had another friend I went to school with
his name is Terrence
he he he watched wrestling so he knew
what to do so we're walking together
right he sit there and he ambushes me
ambushes me sleazy on the ground pigs me
take the belt backstage like yo my
friends gonna come see my friend Tyler
in a week I got a week to win this belt
back going no matter where you are the
parents pointed to and said he's never
coming back here
my mom's would have do like like Tyler
if you're watching man yeah we did like
I am sorry dude like like we did like
but I mean lost three sort I'd end up
winning the championship back in and I
voluntarily lost it so he can have his
chicken I want to be responsible cuz
that belt cuz it was like a two hundred
dollar bail you know then he saw I was
like not yeah I was Wow but it was
playing on like the PlayStation 2 and so
64 is what inspired us to we got we had
a theme song so that is true baby's
history bro
you may have topped it like this
he really was doing so we got a speed
for but I gotta ask you the question
that I asked all the guests yeah
top five games or franchises of all time
of all time this is pretty hard
all right boy franchises okay mmm damn
this is listen I'm give you this because
even if whatever we bring you back like
I'm gonna ask dream kind gran Cascais
you're next you have a chance to revise
it if you forgot something cuz you know
you call right so on the spot but you
all right
fried franchises of all time yes okay I
would say being I do this because I
gotta go was based on me and with how
this is your personal thing influenced
you as a gamer
alright what's Musa go ahead to say see
it these the th I think the THQ the
Smackdown serious and I respect these
Super Mario franchise Tendo love that's
what's up the Halo franchise alright
that's the best box there we go go Gears
of War in there because and then the
other franchise may there's so much is
gonna be unfair man there's I just got
back got to do it of what really got
really got me in that had impact for I
want to say the ratchet ain't clinks but
I really want to say the NBA Street
franchise oh that's tough
oh I can see both of them re yeah like
it was this four-year period for my 2001
to 2004 where when an NBA Street came
out like like it did wonders for me you
know three courts just stealing people
basketball steam
officialy challenge of people wrestling
like you do now I could play basketball
but I I'm not good and bad want to be
get winning anything from it you got to
make the tough choice gun to your
personal get with anybody else think
this is your personal listed game and
influenced you the most right I said I
said smarter Halo in the gears the last
one would be weird intro blood board
touch I'm gonna say no what
I'll give it I'll give it to I'm gonna
give it to Ratchet and Clank all right
all right no that's that's that's strong
that's Dora Lord Dreamcast guy you have
been I've gone through the treatment but
I'm giving you a chance if you need to
make any revision to your top 5 now is
the chicas guys he still there as you
fight the dog what's going on so we may
have lost them so last week's results
are in in the people have spoken to the
question when a game of degeneration or
critically-acclaimed title as scores a
perfect 10 by media outlets does your
view change if minor flaws are found
during the gameplay experience the
winner at 45% is the yes but only if the
floor disrupts or affects the main
gameplay experience
coming in at second at 34% is the no
minor nitpicks cannot affect the
masterpiece at third place at 15% was
any flaws found automatically disqualify
attend and in last place at 6% I don't
care unless it's fake HD are small
puddles or the word boy
is overused all the lords of disability
it last week spoke about this man about
a perfect 10 again with getting a
perfect 10 okay are in solo Dreamcast
guys back I see lucky job guys gotta
hear me my my internet keeps randomly
crashing a really hour or so I'm sorry
okay with two questions I want to ask
you real quick I'm glad yeah one was we
did kiss moves on top five this is your
opportunity if you need to revise your
top five and then I want to ask you
about the poll so your top five gaming
franchises of all time do we need any
revisions let me think I just want to
make sure I'm pretty sure I didn't say
Grandia last time I won't do grandi I
feel like nobody the more I feel that
can play great it's a gradient
that's good that's one I see so my five
just off top my head five franchise I'd
say
Grandia Legend of Zelda right Final
Fantasy for sure because Final Fantasy
was a massive inspiration of my wife
fact I'd say Resident Evil because I
think it basically brought for
mainstream in a way way for being bad
like surely survival horror before it
and there we thrive a horror after it
but I was such a landmark game series
and for my fist was released my fifth me
think I'm a dude Diablo because the out
okay perfect avid to and did in
reference to the poll question we just
had in reference to a game scoring the
perfect ten looks like the the Lords of
the realm voted are the unanimous was
the forty five percent were that uh they
said only if they floor and again
disrupts the effect or affects the main
gameplay experience that's when they
their view of a perfect ten changes what
is your view when game scores attend and
if a minor
found does that take that away from you
in a masterpiece when you always kill a
masterpiece but my thing is only if the
flaw undercuts something about the
entire experience even if it's a small
way so I Eve when I reviewed spider-man
I give it a 9 point 5 out of 10 because
I thought the entire plot was cool I
thought that the the combat was great
the city was giant the collectibles were
fun but the game was just too easy
and so at the end I couldn't give it a
perfect score simply because a game that
doesn't require you to think about the
talent tree but has a talent tree does
feel like a tiny bit of a game without
grading like at all yeah exactly but
that's the thing of other than that it's
a perfect game all right look it's
smooth I mean I feel like the scoring
system mom it's flawed because like a
perfect ten like can it have flaws yes
it can now is it the thing is is that
because I feel like there's games that
were like really good like that did
things that did things masterful right
but there was a third thing that he
didn't do that great like for example if
a game is really like really good I say
the game plan enjoyed playing a big game
play loot in the game play it so let's
say if it's repetitive right right but
the story's dope but I enjoyed the
gameplay loop right or is it is it bad
because the gameplay loop is repetitive
but even though I'm enjoying the hell
out of it mmm like or let's say a game
has a very good a very good gameplay
right but the story is average it's not
bad but it's not it's no Hollywood it's
just something that complements the game
you're playing now is it does that make
it really bad is like should you not
enjoy playing a game because it's not
this story like that's why I started to
look at my PO what validates these
reviews what validates a perfect score
ma'am
honestly to at that point is released
down to the individual playing a game
they like but I can understand why for
example a spider-man it could be a ten
out of ten
to somebody else and I don't know a
7-iron San next person maybe you don't
like the gameplay loop but I always look
at games that are rated a perfect 10 um
with a side I because I do decide great
points the fans have spoken but I
definitely wouldn't get you to switch
perspective on it so let's get into the
meat and potatoes here what we are here
oh yeah let me do something real quick
um so last week of this patreon related
so last week two Lords that won the $10
and the $20 gift card giveaway spoke
graciously I decided to reroll it for
the rest of the patron so big shout out
and thank you too Lord loaded pixels and
Lord optimist code oh thank you guys I'm
sure the rest of the patrons appreciated
as well so we're just gonna reroll that
real quick right some prizes man that's
got some prizes okay so the $10 gift
card goes to Lord Michael Liu go punch
these guys are winning every week it's
our golden announced - uh what I'm doing
- since we'll do anyway is shiny because
he ought to Pedro you lost me at it I'm
giving I'm gonna let our first patreon
take my tier the next month so you know
that's right okay I'll do that
right I'll do that right after I do this
doing it all now
so the $20 card goes to
[Laughter]
it's a little whiskey that's what's hard
whiskey salute ma'am no congrats and
thanks again to the optimist code and
loaded pixels so what addict was talking
about is that as a special thank you to
our very first patron Lord Michael Lugo
aka monkey punch yes addict is gonna
give out uh what his tier is for free
for next month so Lord Lugo it is on you
to pick a game that you want addict to
stream you can torture him as much as
you want and so select wisely but you
get one man only give one stream is fun
yeah it is very fun it is very fun so
Lord Lugo apart from the $10 give cold
you never getting me to give up right
there your Chi has permanence to it you
can't you better make it there make sure
like I said you say the game if you want
to put in the chat now you want to reach
out to attic and let us know we'll
stream that thing on the IOP channel and
get everybody all riled up but that's
dope addict that's what's up good we got
down to business has been taking care of
Oh just real quick we didn't have any
fight talk but if you are MMA fans watch
last night's UFC fight night the main
event between the iron Rodriguez and the
Korean Zombie was paradise yeah I've
been playing that time it's [ __ ] hell
lair
[Laughter]
MMA fans definitely check out I'm sure
probably did anyway UFC Fight Night 139
last night some history made Donald
Cerrone became the all-time winningest
fighter in UFC history um that's amazing
for a guy who's never won to strap in
UFC
this dude is he's just a beast he's just
a beast and in the main event for me
went down as one of the kind of an
all-time great yes oh yeah Rodriguez
versus Chang seung-jun aka the Korean
Zombie ah it was interesting to see how
you're eerily good to come back after
getting smoked by Frankie Edgar and he
actually replaced Edgar in this fight um
the ending is one of the greatest
endings I've seen in a fight ever he
knocked out the Korean Zombie with one
second left in the fight and Korean
Zombie was winning that fight you need
to watch it
I'm fishermen dude walk around with his
arms up in front of them in a fight
because he kind of takes a lot of
punishment just keeps coming like he did
like he just doesn't stop
[Laughter]
so what we are all here for to being
potatoes young so X 18 Mexico City Fan
Fest is upon us it was tons tons of
announcements tons of news so we got the
panel here we got your building we got
kids move best spot you know so we got
to talk about these impressions and I
actually want to start off with Lord Jim
Casca
because I'm curious about his
perspective on the show I know we talk
pre-show yes raw emotions but I wanted
him to save it what was your overall
impressions of this show uh I think the
presentation was great
I think the way they set stuff up and
tried to pace it out with smarts I like
the fact that the fans were so happy
they'd scream about anything that was
said even if it was weeny the Pooh
puzzle games but I don't anything there
was super crazy cool to me the only
thing there that really like actually
melted my brain it was so awesome was
the crackdown free footage like the fact
that they finally came out and went okay
here's crackdown 3 coop there's a 5v5
mode like the fact that they're finally
just really unleashing all the the
crackdown 3 stuff that was cool
everything else about the thing though
the fact that there was a two-hour live
stream way too much they should have
been it should have been twenty minutes
my opinion say you know the land people
flipping out or everything like boys
calves he made up a good point no
there's not a lot I don't think there's
a lot of events in Mexico so like they
probably were just like extremely
excited to be there because there's a
lot of the things there Xbox is massive
I did some research at word Xbox is the
biggest console in Mexico everybody owns
an Xbox everybody who plays games are
less so because of it like this was like
the the way the way the Nintendo
switches right now in Japan where if you
go on the trains everybody has a switch
that's the way it is there so when the
fact that Microsoft went there for a fan
event of course everyone's gonna be like
Microsoft is here realize that that's
beautiful that's a beautiful thing
that's pretty interesting alright cool
so you got there I want to get a kid
small in the building I need these
impressions what stood out for you how
did you feel about the show if anybody
watch my what to expect from XO 18 dad
did on October 5th I was like six of
eight
without everything that expected and so
that's why I can't be mad now
the thing is when I'm when watch that
EXO 18 I didn't watch to be entertained
and I didn't watch for anything else
other but then news and information I
wanted news I wanted crackdown I wanted
a release date I wanted gameplay like I
went in a surety that it was coming and
I got what I wanted
you know from crackdown new studios
mm-hmm yeah I can't be I can't be mad
it's some updates to stay the case see
if these having a new battle mode and
stuff like that like oh okay some things
that actually wanted from some games
that you know that's been like
quote-unquote disappointed mom Xbox one
is getting $100 discount for Black
Friday that's cool yes oh don't give you
10 seconds can we please point out the
major knows me to get to be but gets are
you good yeah the gamepad support the
mouse and keyboard support that they're
doing the games that supported there's
some games that they listed that I was
surprised that they did it and um
they got like the fortnight support on
that so it was like like as far as a
show no I mean I know I didn't really
care for the show itself but I'm not
gonna deny like the information that I
got the news and information I was
completely satisfied with the news
information because I got what I want
I wanted from from the show so that's
why I finally I don't really get what
like the complaints are for like it's
like we got news information if the show
was whack the show is wet but I'm not
gonna say are you telling me the show
was trash or the information that you're
mad that they bought two Studios or
you're mad that this game is getting
update or you met that crackdowns not
push back and it's pushed up like what
like what is there to be mad I don't
know so I understand the the outcry as
far as people being disappointed with
the show like you feel from an
information standpoint it satisfied you
yeah because what are you watching for
if you ain't what you what are you
watching me entertained are you watching
for news it who do not
like think about it why would we go to
packs and [ __ ] like that why do we go to
e3 and think it's like at the end of the
day short beer they III gives off a
better presentation of things but at the
end of the day what we really want is
what we want breaking news information
and sure we and I think is sure this
wasn't no III level of news information
but it was information I don't think
that you're too far off with you saying
that it wasn't III level because I beg
to differ when it comes to to that
pleasing Spencer was there the lord save
the king of who did there for you um the
shoutout master of y'all didn't know
he's here um I'm gonna let you know his
petit was hanging so he was out there
petit I'm gonna tell you right now i'ma
call this axle petty show mmm because
they they I mean okay the structure of
this show I'm not a fan of okay I am NOT
a fan of it I'm not a fan of the fake
laughter the fake enthusiam not a I'm
not a fan of the fakeness right but I
understand that they have to do this in
this fake world that they that they're
making up and I see what they're doing I
don't I don't agree with it alright I
agree with the information I agree with
the messaging I agree with them trying
to have more interaction with the fans
now what y'all are forgetting that they
had a fan fest there right
alright so if you ever been part of fan
fest big debt debt debt debt energy from
the crowd
that's severe that's real yeah because
they're interacting with them throughout
this whole time what you don't see on
camera but you don't get a chance to see
when they do get a chance to talk to
these guys when they do tell them to
scream I don't think they're probably
right now they're feeding them letting
them play they tell them the yellow sea
of thieves they started yelling I'll see
if these because they probably saw it
they're so enthusiastic they know how to
build a crowd yeah I think you know
there's probably not a lot of people
that's actually been a fan fest' like
most of the people on the panel have me
Laurel Cardinal and Lord King David
we've been to I've been to two kognito
you've been to three all right like I
can assure you like right now in King
David's he's you're on your third one
all right yes
I can assure you they do not ask you to
yell out like weird stuff like all that
stuff was genuine the crowd enthusiasm
that stuff was genuine the the principle
people that was on stage a lot of that
stuff was contrived in force okay
there's discern people that's in place
there that I don't badmouth them because
they have a job and they have a job to
do and they're doing the job that they
asked to do and they're doing a good job
at what they're asked to do that's fine
all right information wise like kids
move said it was big because for all the
people this is where petty comes in Phil
made sure that you got a date Phil made
sure that you saw gameplay and film made
sure that that game looked better than
what you saw before
you can't deny any of those things from
from so basically from a crackdown
perspective was it the greatest show
ever that's debatable like you know I
feel like I feel like the inside Xbox
inside I'm really starting to feel like
that you know it's just what it is like
these are not for us it's a commercial
they're just on it was a commercial to
sell game pass don't castle
yeah and I think that's not game passes
the center of everything they're doing I
hate did you notice that Phil said a few
million is subscribed to game pass yes
return to the realm this is the perfect
person yeah in the realm is good to be
awful lock I wanted to make sure that
you made sure you watch my movements
without that whole thing was going down
like I said you know I'm friends with
everybody Hannibal for you guys I don't
I don't you know i don't blame nobody
it's just you know it was one of those
things it it happened and you know it is
what it is you know I'm good I got my
count back I'm back doing what I do know
about that multiplayer and crackdown boy
so this man could take his time and do
his thing alright this is the petty part
okay
they know that Sony is out selling over
PlayStation now okay so what they did
was they said how the hell can we
undercut these tools a dollar a hundred
games a dollar and it kept beating us in
your head
for the whole two hours that you watched
alright so if you have an xbox and you
didn't get a chance to see the show with
you do see the show you're gonna beat in
the head for two hours to let you know
that you know game past is a dollar for
the first time you try so they're trying
to get everybody who has alive or who
has a silver to see this and say what
dollar and join all right so they ditch
up they're pushing that that pub G the
help of G and beta
they have pub G
the pre crafted I did I wasn't about but
I brought it and I played it I support
the game the game came out on full
release now the game is going to be
released on PlayStation 4 full retail
price right next yeah
they say guess what move we go I agree
away from you yep and we're gonna make
it feel like feces in your sock free bed
if you sign up right now you gonna get
pop G for $1 what do you mean oh honey
before if you had done it before
blackout wouldn't be a factor the
PlayStation version not a soul cares
about that game if you played it before
you don't care about it now for what it
is is that win because that's a big win
for that game to be over there because
these dudes just running around talent
you don't remember that was that game of
the show that was a big golden goose
that was the prize it's gold 9 million
hmm so it's going to PlayStation now and
these PlayStation dudes was gonna run
around with a flag on my watch you ever
come to PlayStation that's gonna be my
game of the year
[Music]
obviously we were going at it was
hilarious item the Jacob or Kratos
impressions
hey eight and I might surprise you guys
right obviously you know I just Warren
Jeffs and said that's what I do but I
actually you know I actually thought
that the event was a good event for the
Xbox fan base
oh yeah I know I'm gonna tell you why
right let me tell you all right
this show was just like PSX is for
PlayStation fans this was exclusively
for Xbox ran this event was not to win
over a Playstation and Nintendo dues it
was to make people with the Xbox fans
aware of game paths and what's coming in
the future the game pass and where the
future is going with Xbox I think I
think they captured that now this is
where it went wrong right
it was the youtubers in the Twitter head
that overhyped this by putting up these
rumors about damn by a man and all of
this you know we're gonna get halo
infinite gameplay possibly Gears 5 yeah
stuff like that really over sales and if
nothing I'm ready to bring these games
then feel me I mean honestly
they can't come they can't compete with
that right you you're always gonna be
you know be like alright this was a
letdown this was a letdown because it
was now it didn't live up to what you
wanted to live up to so again I get
where this comes from now here's the
thing this show was not for me it was
not tailored to me I'm I'm a different
type of gamer and I know how to borrow
down on the I know how to say look well
this isn't for me but for somebody else
if you're just getting into the
ecosystem dan hey man you this is white
you know the price of the S is dirt
cheap you can get that you can spend $1
$10 to get game pass you get all these
games I get who is targeted towards now
the problem is when you take the
hardcore gamer like you know most of us
on the panel right
how does what was in that for you oh
well isn't in that for you now again
gaming is a selfish hobby it's not about
everybody else it's about meaning what
can I get out of it oh I didn't get
anything out of so therefore I'm gonna
just bow down sit down and keep doing
what I do what I'm gonna you know what
I'm doing now here's here's another
problem right it kind of seems like
Microsoft is almost pushing people
towards the PC platform whereas you know
they got a lot of games that are coming
specifically on PC you know we already
seen the Age of Empires we're already
seeing stuff like that and a lot of
these games are coming day in date to PC
so feels said we want you to play any
and everywhere but you know again we're
attached a lot of us are old heads we're
attached to the hardware we're tested
this console this gives the the the this
particular Xbox it gives its identity if
you don't have an identity then what I
don't want
Xbox but that's just personally I don't
want X bar to be a service I don't want
it to be little now I want to stand
outside waiting for the console waiting
to go back to war and I think here's
here's a major problem in our wrap-up
people when they look at Xbox they are
looking for that great comeback boxing
story that rocky versus looking you know
we want Microsoft to spin the bans and
go toe to toe for every game Sony drop
lamb Hitler came to counter that they're
looking for that now here's the thing I
just don't think that that's going to
come because then I think Sony I mean I
think Microsoft is looking for its own
identity on worst one in the future
there's gonna be the services it's gonna
be the streaming thing and that's just
kind of where it's gonna be so us you
gotta looking forward for this next
great bit comes all to blow the PS 5 out
of water for all these big games to
counter all of the big games they have I
think if we go in with that in mind
we're always going to be late because
there are no longer trying to do that
let me get sauce off you've been
chomping ahead my competitions like
cradle says I don't think the
competition is direct anymore I think
Microsoft had
is looking at something much more
expanded so like it's it's almost a very
indirect competition now because they
don't they're not engaging head-to-head
anymore because a it's not in the best
interest to do it right especially not
now that they don't have anything ready
to announce and he's like you said it
was made it clear that he's gonna heat
that he is dedicated to making sure that
Xbox is always gonna be there as a
platform and as a box you'll have it in
your house and it will be a powerful box
but again he has to he has to walk that
line right like the narrative has to be
general because he has to push the
services and push the fact that you're
gonna be playing this stuff on your
phone on whatever else on your computer
so he cannot he can't focus it solely on
Xbox anymore even if you if he does it
he if he follows it through the xbox
name yeah it's like it's not that direct
competition anymore not you can't please
everybody that's the problem right I
can't please everybody I know they're
trying to get the two billion gamers the
problem with that right if I gain came
with candy crush on my cell phone I am
not I'm not I'm not going to be the
consumer that's gonna play Halo on
myself
oh I cut you bro we've got some Xbox
royalty to just knock it just chordal
from the Xbox to in Windows Central is
this there you go is this I see I see
that avatar from across the pond sir yes
I get we wait for his bike but continue
j-dub and then we'll get Jesse I'm sorry
the stuff that he has to say is really
important so j-dub it is hopefully
Jessica definitely no I was just saying
that the people like you know my wife
died play candy crush and all these
mobile games
she will never play a Halo or Gears or
4s or any of those Xbox game
on her cell phone no we got we got
driven yeah Jessica Mic Check there sir
no we hear you we know I was going on
Jess yeah but I was just saying that
people like her you know even though
she's she's to me she's not a gamer but
Microsoft hired her as a Jane you know I
couldn't if I tried get to get her to
sit down to play xbox with me replace a
she just that's that's the whole beauty
of this gaming thing is because she is a
gamer you know Jesus happens the game on
hunting of choice if it's a cell phone a
tablet because you know my girl sister
she she games on her tablet as you play
puzzle games and I can't take that from
her and you know I can't take how she
games you know we're diverse group we
are very diverse like you may like and
you know you just gotta make like
shooters like and whistle diverse so
yeah we are all gamers and I understand
you're like 15 million people playing
farmville in 2012 exactly where
everybody is saying and I know that see
I met odds with that what'd you say
cradles that's why I believe that it's
two different systems is coming like
they're gonna have that system that that
we want that we need then go in the
store and the purchase and put it in the
house and then you're gonna have that
service for those other people that need
to gain that weight and I feel what
you're saying like they're not directly
competing with one entity there's got a
chaton
and in this scattershot it maybe I just
want to say this as vaguely as possible
so I don't give away anybody like who
has told me some stuff but I will say
that Xbox is at this point really
preparing for the next generation the
Xbox two they're buying studios they're
preparing groundwork they want to have a
streaming console and a standard console
and their plan here is to see a very
weekend PlayStation 5 because the next
generation is not just going to be the
Nintendo switch or maybe the switch Pro
it's not just gonna be the PlayStation
five it's not gonna be the Xbox two
there's gonna be another game console on
the market as well and I think they're
hoping that that weakens Sony enough
that they can come in and just drop a
bunch of games in like 2020 and take
over
mmm enough Anna Lord jazz xbox royalty
can you hear me serve all areas
discussion here we're talking about the
Xbox obviously EXO 18 impression so I
want to get your feel on the show where
you at with it as a whole we need the
floors yours well I already knew I
couldn't I couldn't of course you know
it's if anyone listens to me in mind
absolutely you know last week I think
it's important to note that they they
called it an inside Xbox show it wasn't
its own thing they didn't want it to be
you know its own thing on the level of
III and stuff like that it was like EXO
is gonna be this like traveling fan fest
sort of thing I travel around the world
let people get hands-on time with
upcoming games like you know people in
Mexico right now playing the late the
current so yeah more of a hands-on sort
of thing
yes the idea is and I think it's
important to know that they did call it
inside Xbox not yes thing no it was just
by staying inside Xbox on steroids I
think me and run said it was gonna be
okay okay so so yeah you guys a whole
not not to cut you but you as a whole
because you've come in you've kind of
already knew and you've come in with the
expectation that this is an inside Xbox
as opposed to kinda
I can III can you at least understand
some fans upset being upset their
dissatisfaction with the fact that some
people feel like it was really hyped
almost like an e3 level and that maybe
you know maybe the pacing and certain
things were just not there for them
because that's a lot of things I'm
seeing also on Twitter yeah I mean I
watched the life I didn't know how the
pacing would go down and stuff like that
I just sort of the big news hits like I
just watching it with some friends and
when they you know the the Minecraft
segment was oh thank you God you said we
weren't lying I have a pre-recorded I'm
gonna wait for stuff to calm down that
I'm gonna post it but I was like I
almost ended it for that I was like this
is this is and one that I like at the
beginning I was okay they say bad didn't
they did the cats and and pay anything
to be fair you gotta realize now like I
said before we aren't yeah it's not for
us we are in the minority right now
right the majority are the people that
play Minecraft and oak all these other
games they're you know looking for the
big the meat and potatoes on the plate
we're looking for the gears the halo you
know all the next GM big blockbuster
stuff yeah that stuff is is that stuff
is years away because I'm chomping right
now he just acts just something real
quick before like I don't know if he can
comment on this
you play crackdown 3 you know you played
that version I noticed that one thing
that wasn't really fill it about it like
there was some hardcore aim-assist going
on there like it was it was worse than
the rockstars like from the stamp are
you aware if that's available took offer
was that for purely a presentation
standpoint these core to the gameplay
mechanics oh gosh
the first thing you should stop thinking
about we cracked the only study - sure
[Music]
PvP game I I started playing it like I
was playing a hunter in World of
Warcraft or something because you know
is it fun is it really fun uh well the
cloud tech the post practing 3 has been
the night the the the reason this is
taking so long to get out is because of
this cloud poet aqui
it threw up all sorts of complications
limitations that microsoft and their
partners didn't anticipate right so
really they haven't had anywhere near as
long as people think to actually put the
gameplay on top of the the crowd the
cloud destruction because cloud
destruction had to be in a position
where it was a consumer ready product
yes they're there now but it's you know
run out of time that's what I play was
they emphasized very very much that it
was unfinished like the gameplay on top
was unfinished the UI was unfinished
it was there's bits of UI that didn't
work properly and obviously like they
they had like plans for monetization but
those have been removed now a few months
ago like there's no not gonna be loot
crate's or anything like that in it
thank God and then one of the reasons
they've shown it often now is to gather
some sort of feedback from decided that
that's the pool whatever
but you know it was it was fun you know
you like jumping around blown up
buildings thought that bit was fun but I
sort of felt like I mastered the game
like I wrote my preview I felt like I
mastered the game by the third match
gasps and it felt like there's not much
more to this because like the way it
works is when you when someone's locked
onto you you see like a red line yeah
and that means that there
they're locked on and they've got
line-of-sight if it's a grey light that
means they're locked on and they don't
have one of so so idea is to lockup
really thing between you and then yeah
the idea is to put a building between
you and the enemies on to the rebuilding
to get away from them and then you plan
your own you plan of attack or you use a
jump pad to like spin across the map and
stuff like that so like it's more about
your movement your knowledge of map I
like using the map to your advantage and
stuff more than daddy could see when you
play that just have one more small
question was the diameter around they
owe you around was it was it a big or
could you like lock-on on the other side
of the map if you wanted to now you
should you have to like you can always
see the enemies like you can always see
where they are because if the maps are
very very vertical as I feel like yes it
it'd be disorienting if you couldn't if
you are you being shot from above or
something and you couldn't find where
they are I feel like it'd be for
spraying so you you know what you can
always see where the enemies are you
cannot walk onto them if you've got
line-of-sight
so let me let me ask you this because
you're mentioning line-of-sight you're
mentioning verticality and you actually
mentioned something some concerns I had
because I know graph visually it looked
good I felt it made a strong statement
that cloud tech is working and that the
game actually looks functional but my
concern was kind of what you're alluding
to which is that the hardcore gameplay
loop right like if we're talking like
this auto lock on thing is it kind of
like a rocket launch where you have to
kind of sink someone up kind of aim at
them for a bunch of seconds and then
lock on and it's that kind of a deal
like explore a little bit more on that
lock-on it's more like more like GTA
style you just you just press the
trigger and you snap to them okay and
then you as long as you're holding that
trigger down you're still locked on to
them even if they behind a building or
they're running across a walkway so like
the way I was playing it was when they
slipped through a building or something
you switched to your heavy weapon so you
got two weapons one is like a weapon
you know like a soul rifle or shotgun
that's aimed at killing players okay
these huge rocket weapons which are more
the bullets travel more slowly because
their rockets or plasma or whatever good
hitting players if the players are
moving around do damage to players but
they're if the players are moving around
fast enough they won't hit them a blown
a building got you different player
flips out on the site you switch your
rocket launcher now we keep it for the
kids where we keep it relaxed like you
blow a hole in the building so you can
get learn decided so I had like I got
some on a personal clip see me playing
it on Twitter later um you know the
thing I wrote the way I closed my
preview was it made me excited
the future of gaming like ice alone
either supplied to Gears of War I'd love
to see this apply to halo but I was more
excited for the future of gaming than I
was for crackdown multiplayer that's why
I think they sound worrisome to me like
I mean anytime you have a PvP mode and
you're telling me that it's not a free a
mode and you're locking on that's you
you can't limit the gameplay options
there and then like you said like now
you're worried about like you know
destructive weapons as opposed to
weapons to use against other players and
stuff like that like that just seems
weird to me and I I think the tech is
the most impressive stuff and all of
this and seeing it applied to an actual
shooter like a Halo or Gears that to me
it does seem more interesting because
this mm-hmm
do do you think that wolf enough you
know criticism do you think they might
make lobbies that doesn't have a lock on
I think that's probably something that
explore I mean I don't see because I
feel like that I'll you know give people
a good middle ground maybe you're in
ranked matches that don't have it right
you miss the ability to toggle it off
right you can't do that though because
if some people haven't something
well done' yeah I'd be real bad they
tried that for a short time in GTA
online and lock on players were just
getting all the kills um one it one
portion that interests me specifically
was the four-player cooperative story
element was that available to demo our
test they they said in that literature
that it was full play Club but they told
me that it was to play after it started
off with four player co-op and then it
just somewhere at some point in time
it's switch yeah before it was four
player co-op the last time was not this
eighty-three what a point us III cuz
they showed it this time it looked
better but maybe they've reduced
introduced to play account I want to
point out though that the images I don't
know if it's like Oh marketing stuff
they're sharing but it still has four
people on the cover like maybe that you
know that's the other day I think twos
mine but you know not good look better
right
like having not for is not gonna be like
yeah I'm not messing with crackdown like
a lot of a lot of mouse was shut with
that full destructibility out so
whatever they because I heard debt to be
fair right we saw this game four or five
years ago yes and with the power of the
tech and stuff like that if this game
was supposed to be a much larger game on
a much bigger scale
it was and now it seems and I'm assuming
right I don't know I'm assuming there
was problems in the background they had
to do something they probably scrapped
what they were working with and built
the game that we're gonna get and it's
actually like it just may not and I
haven't played it yet
but I feel like it may not live up to
people's expectations for a game that
had been hyped for so many years it's
gonna you know it's we've had games like
that before look at what the the
PlayStation game that took like 20 years
Guardian yeah The Last Guardian
right this this feels like it's gonna be
Xboxes Final Fantasy 15 it's not bad
followed it the closest are gonna be
heavily let down by everybody everybody
followed this game it was on deadly it
was on five five years straight it was
on the list of the greatest lineup in
history we want to see that listen they
have to cater to the least common
denominator which is the regular Xbox
that is true all right so you gonna ask
for destructive but I mean the folks on
X I'm pretty sure that everybody's X
will look like that first time that they
showed it with each bullet all going in
the wall I'm pretty sure later will look
fantastic but that is running around
with the world yes question for you and
I've been like Xbox to chat where do you
see the Xbox one X in the next like two
years two to three years obsolete the
Xbox one because I'm just struggling cuz
we when they heard a little bit kid
the whole cuz you know how to get the
whole car thing in this their servers is
built up of a bunch of like Xbox one SS
bike bike III guess I'm like loss of
like like what happens there like like
is so you're saying that's is so the
next-generation Xbox is gonna replace
the X and it's gonna be that and
whatever the cloud thing so the S is
probably gonna die off first and then
the X is you probably say guys make
another year or two now smooth the your
your iPhone is gonna make that obsolete
iPad it's gonna make you remember all
these billions of mobile devices is
gonna make the X obsolete I mean the
iPad pro 2 is strong yes yeah my pure
numbers mobile I'm podcasting on it
right now I mean our ball is such a
bigger business than console it's not
the reason
and it's almost bigger than all of Xbox
and PlayStation c'mon DS yeah and I
think that's the thing that people
forget about when you know stuff like
the Diablo stuff happens it's like they
they they tend to forget that like even
when it comes to the console market the
mobile markets like triple what would
the console market
yeah it's nothing it's nothing you know
that's why that's why mark says push me
so hard into Project X player they've
got like bigger aspirations they want a
piece of that mobile pie yeah yeah why
that's why you got Blizzard pushing some
towards mobile and stuff like that yeah
well let me ask you this dress because
you mentioned another point in reference
to your overall crackdown thing which
was that you actually took from it that
even though maybe the game itself was ok
not terrible but ok like you felt that
this was almost a spring forward for the
future and you're actually excited for
an outlook on the future yeah I'll give
you a quote I mean this is literally
what the the mark software Xbox has had
an engineer told me is that 90% of the
work they've done in the last few years
was been was poured into the cloud tech
so like the last 10% of the time they've
spent working on crackdown has been
actually making again I think well in
that case does that mean that you have a
basis where you can you can package you
can package have
in the cloud big deal big deal
can I ask this question real quick - go
for it
just to join you guys so as I stated
before as the hardcore gamers where do
you see us within the next five years
within it with the X bar I mean again
like we always do no no I'm trying to
find out where where do I fit in the
Xbox system going for any Xbox ecosystem
going forward I get the mobile thing I
get all of that mm-hmm but just for the
simple guy just for the old-fashioned
guy where what what do we fit in
you have to listen right every time
every time they talk about X cloud every
single time they always mention that
more Xbox hardware's on the way they
always in that position
you know yeah in the Xcode video they
actually say a paraphrase they say
something like the premium experience
will always be on the console and the
fact that the fact that the server
blades the apparent X cloud road on the
Xbox one air should tell you about the
kind of quality you're gonna get over
lilo it's gonna be kind of max out at
nine hundred 1080p it's it's designed
for you know bitrate and speed it's not
designed for high fidelity gameplay in
play you have to buy that Xbox one X or
this or whatever they're gonna call it
and and you know PlayStation 5 and stuff
like that and it'll be the same for Sony
expand PlayStation now and it'll be
hopefully a competing service against
project stream project things but the
experience will always be on that box
and the the whole a whole point of this
is to you know it gives developers like
Rockstar and it gives them absolute CD
Projekt RED additional revenue source so
they can start pushing towards you know
8k games in hundred 20s and you can
suppose the industry you know gets more
people jobs in the industry makes games
more competition my ex games even more
crazy and you know God knows where you
could be in ten years if they if they
can crack if they can bring core gaming
to mobile and convert some of those
candy crush people into core gamers
that's just more money for us guys to
enjoy the industry getting even more
crazy I mean sure you know this way
maybe everyone just starts making like
they blow him all games and pay the win
and maybe a godly other way I mean my
little cook she's and she's done in the
last two years is play world of time you
know to play like I try to make a play a
real game and just like why would I why
would I buy a game or denied and see for
her that the normal business model is
free to fire you Marga translations
that's normal for us that's kind of
scary that you know they have been
groomed in this manner that free-to-play
is that with these micro transaction and
his loot crate's
in a way that their dead piece Mealing
you the piece of the poll pie and I
don't like that part I do wanna I hate
it that's why I hate it when journalists
attack games like read the redemption
because it's like yeah okay they work
hard and crunches bad and all that sort
of stuff but like if you are these games
like ready redemptions which really
capture mainstream attention and boy is
read there you know read there's in
mainstream press and being talked about
on mainstream news outlets those are the
games that are sort of reminding the
public this is what a game is supposed
to be like I hunted down play games like
read evidently that's her in the core
gaming industry and which is ultimately
where where the coin edge of the art of
gaming lives nice and I think candy
crush it's known table more all those
there its cash cows for these companies
and I'm sure Bobby Kotick and you know
whoever is running the
I don't even know his name I'm sure they
would love it if the the whole industry
was just these sort of easy simplistic
piecemeal experiences like you say a
purely funded with market transactions
and their predatory and stuff I'm sure
everything would that but luckily we've
got devs like rock star and said you
Projekt RED that are sort of reminding
us at a curiosity you know inside xbox I
clearly you know felt like it had bad
pacing but I wanted to ask you know
question of Lords do you think that
obsidian being linked to soon hurt the
impact of it being announced yeah I feel
so you think if no one would have known
that they would have kept adjacent rides
and stuff from you know jump in so like
what I said is right like this was an
inside Xbox Show I hear what you say kid
this is definitely that and that's why I
kept my expectations level the problem I
had and again I'm not blaming Microsoft
I'm not blaming my feeling is just that
once it started to get closer to the
release date you know you get your
countdown five days four days three days
the feel I got was like it was a mini e3
that was the feel hold you guys last
week last week do what it did look the
first hour I'm with you King I felt he
was strong right I felt hub G was a
chess move okay all know it's coming to
ps4 what's the best way to stop that
momentum though that bad boy in a ingame
pass you know I'm saying you really
effectively kill that momentum that they
had of taking that call
quote exclusive I'm like that crack down
to me that was Phil's moment okay boom
regardless of how the gameplay loop will
end up being we don't know because we
haven't played it the game looked
visually good the destruction looked
good and it was real it wasn't you know
pie in the sky stuff it regardless to
the scope of it you may have an issue
with that the fact that it delivered on
the stage finally for this game has been
kept behind closed doors for so long and
it didn't it Barris itself that was
amazing it didn't in Barry look strong
so shout out to jazz you know tremendous
article club real all you guys have been
you guys guys got me hype about it but
we'll talk this show to meet glorified
game pass reveal it was it was it was
listen for the fans I get it you know
the way I look at it is like two pacing
oh my god the pacing like think they
could have condensed the first hour
maybe throw the man booty thing up I
just feel like they have great
information to share but the problem is
it always comes down to the presentation
when you watch a Nintendo Direct right
it's short it's concise it's boom boom
boom and then maybe you get a surprise
like oh one more thing right they know
how to cater to the bass when you watch
a swing presentation it's it's very
theatrical
it's very movie like you you're into the
game you're getting into it I'm sorry
when when you get the crazy Larry
segment you don't like a good you know
when you got a friend and you have a
really good friend like bugging out
right now like they don't have that good
friend on the presentation team to say
listen me like this I like
I love Larry malaria's and Larry always
appears as if he's on like always on him
because only to him it's everyone else
that was on that presentation seems the
same thing is like you said it is that
it is that sort of it's too forced it's
too crazy it's too like I said it's like
you know someone that you know they
trying to do something to her and a lot
of that stuff can be eliminated if you
just cut the Phillip you're not I feel
like if you're not in the way he does
but it sounds genuine it's like you know
genuine but it gets thank you
see they have great announcements they
have great information but when you have
those bad pacing issues in those gaps
and these crazy weird goofy things going
on you have now killed all the momentum
that you built up and that's what I
thought the first if they to put bootie
and the announcement and move that to
the end of the first hour kind of
condense the minecraft stuff I thought
the game past announcements were pretty
cool somebody gave the solid what's that
game the XCOM game the mutants there
after charge I played at PAX East that's
a great little voice watch now we got to
get to the missteps know where was ashen
know something I played the game I just
finished playing the game so it's gonna
be at the game we were told it's
definitely in-game pass that was
announced at e3 funny we were told by
the studio right and a pariah multiple
times it's coming in 2018 fam it's
November 11th it's gonna be a part of
winter of Arcade and it has to come out
next month they don't come out next
month I'm screaming at somebody and then
the last the lot the last points for the
standouts for me obviously crackdown
just cause for look phenomenal I thought
that looked amazing
you and your zero that was my chart
stated Acadia shout out to the fog in
accrue them guys are passionate free DLC
I like that everything ends enthusiastic
announcements put on yeah just like they
said no no ashen the minecraft segments
too long crazy 80 Larry segments in the
bushes is that you know the Black Friday
thing we were just we were we rolled our
eyes and I literally tuned out all they
needed to do j-dub is they needed a JPEG
which which is crazy right Victor so
it's crazy because Sony has done that
billion times before the game is not
releasing for 3-4 years but you still
got a fake screenshot I know you still I
mean like deep down remember
they showed that stuff we hadn't seen
that
five years but the problem is they don't
was out yeah because it is now situation
no it's not even the scalebound thing
you know I think that has something to
do with it because they don't want to
announce something some of these games I
highly doubt it's going to get canceled
you know because they just invested
money into these games why would they
camp would you have some could happen in
the developments like I don't know but I
think I don't want to have an issue
where they have to show the same game at
e3 for three years but here's the thing
right it happened you can't leave the
people wanting more and that's what I
think a lot of people are gonna keep
hanging over Microsoft head yeah we're
glad you're finally investing in studios
you've made some major acquisitions and
that's good but we know for a fact we're
not gonna see a lot of these games for
three to four years leading to next
generation so every year right now now
people are ready time I will let's wait
- III let's see if they're gonna show
this at e3 and so this perpetual cycle
keep going just it filled with a walked
out there right after the show and say
look this we got on our plate we got
Fable confirmed BAM it's right there
that screen shot up there we got this
game BAM it's up there showing it at
least people can know these are solid
games that are coming and now that'll
[ __ ] up the naysayers and that'll kind
of quiet down a crowd that at least a
acknowledging but just to say you know
you know well we don't want to talk
about it now you can't be hushed for
three to four years into these games
already you can't I agree with you
kratos but it's like like you said
before they know the audience for this
they know it's the Xbox crowd that's
gonna be there regardless they can occur
the size but they're gonna be there
regardless those are announcements that
are better served at the Game Awards
when they're more eyes on it III
obviously when they're more eyes on it
just it's wishful thinking on our part
and obviously the fan base deserves that
but if as a business move it doesn't
make the most sense to get it out they
even know the fan base once they get
that information they're gonna
disseminate that out right right it
still doesn't have the same impact you
know what it didn't do for us this is
why we met it didn't give us stuff to
tweet about
that's about these two Studios exiled
torment tides of numenera the bards what
our earlier solve I'd have been fine
straight I was like they're making us
watch this minecraft stuff they're
making us watch this stuff that like is
really courage words because they know
we want to speak me now to the end of
the show right they gave you the entire
list and they told you you know some new
announcements to do minecraft is
probably the number one top selling
franchises in my casino again cradles
has hit the nail on the head span do you
have to know the audience also that's
what I'm say it's almost a tone deaf
attitude when it comes to present a lot
of things that went on with you did you
notice the denounce that she was doing
Forza yes
and she wasn't actually controlling the
car did you really look at this so that
part is disingenuous that's the part I'm
talking about where where you you know
you fake an interaction don't do that
don't do that because we're not stupid
we actually know that you staring right
but the car was going left we we know
this we see it but listen let's listen
you know what let's let's stop trying
so hard so hard and just let it do it I
definitely I definitely feel a sovereign
scene and I don't want to I know the
announcements of yeah of those students
great stuff that was a huge what would
Lord King just said I didn't notice that
during the stream but I bet you that's
why she was off that in the middle of I
know like you can I was like they don't
snatch can you call me they about
overreacted what's your feeling on it as
far as presentation specifically what
Microsoft I was totally wasted you're in
the show I don't do it by attitude we
work all friends at the time you know
like during the boring seconds here we
just tried to each other and stuff like
that but and even even though we were
drunk and we were trying we did think is
that you taking this long to talk about
besides it's not for us and minecraft is
the second biggest franchise of all time
behind Tetris by after I have to say
you're right I just like you could be
that long but then you know and still
feel like they're evolving their format
and things only instead like during the
show they sort of like they know they've
got work to do with PCs for example and
it's like they're sort of getting all
their sort of pieces in play before they
figure out figure some of this stuff out
and to be honest not many companies
really completely do this right
perfectly you know I mean in tender kind
of like to interrupt but before for kids
you just realize I just realized that
they'd literally snuck the ability to
pre download game pass bugs that aren't
out yet yes yeah yes
yes and oh one other thing too that
we're not talking about we've overlooked
keyboard and mouse support right and
this again this is just me person is me
being selfish
you I thought that's great right it has
some announcements of games and stuff
like that I was surprised chairs no
gears tactics that's what happened the
perfect time to kind of and grow that in
there man because we're you are both
XCOM guys and i would love to play that
on console as opposed to right now
quote-unquote be it exclusive to the
process i fully expect kids tactics on
xbox okay this is all about messaging in
optics again they want the quad core
stretch strategy game players which do
live on PC they want them to know that
this is being built for PC first so they
feel like I would assume they're
thinking it's not like you say then it's
both they'll think oh it's just going to
be a console port or Webber yeah I
wouldn't know that this is a true
strategy game hardcore you know ii was
pretty much the other way around it was
made for imported to PC and it was
really looked down on in the PC
community they don't want that again too
much and I blame this on a rabid
PlayStation and PC fanboys
messaging dude it's just like just do
what you gotta do man they would they
would do what Sony doesn't offer game
six years in advance you know what I
know what nintendon't cringe work Rado
said well why don't mark us off just you
know put a little thumbnail let's stick
up and do the same thing that everybody
else is doing and you know what I get
you when you say that do that so you can
shut people up so you can know that this
stuff is moving and we can stop the
speculating yeah I know you want to stop
the speculation and you want some
concrete stuff you know what happens
when you put out concrete stuff and then
your concrete stuff gets smashed to
oblivion and this gets thrown away you
get hesitant and doing such a thing
that scalebound I don't care what
anybody says we actually saw it on the
floor I don't know if it was playable
for some other people but I actually was
gonna pre-order the game the same even
though it was in a very bad state you
know um I said well they're gonna clean
it up by the time it's time to get
around you know that slowdown and I see
right there still that little area over
there that I saw there look like a black
wall they're gonna fix that and they
they didn't they didn't come to terms
and the game got canceled and you got
burnt and if you get burnt one too many
times we wear PlayStation is doing these
heavy hitters brother they see these
games
yeah so don't put yourself in a bad
position where you can always be
criticized you want to get praised
sometimes too so sometimes it make sure
you afraid to put that foot out because
the key do you notice that they can
announce like studios and they still get
criticized for it people are I literally
was arguing I don't want them buying
studios I want games
you know you know they only do it to
trigger people like you that they don't
care about Microsoft for Xbox is they
doing it because it's great optics on
Twitter for you is you triggered that's
why it's done now now here's the thing
David I agree with your thousand percent
and wash scalebound it kind of Birnam
and there there were a lot of
PlayStation guys a lot of PC guys and a
lot of PlayStation Xbox guys we're
looking forward to scalebound because it
was Western RPG but more more than not
it was a it was RPG and luckily now
right they see the value in RPGs on
their platform they bought obsidian in
this in this other development so now
that we're getting that right but you
can't keep going with negative and and
you know I'll be the first to say this
right regardless of you know how troll
on Twitter and stuff like that I'm a
gamer first but it's about the it's
about time fulfilled and all those guys
to get that negative fog over the head
of X but it needs to go away it's been
over the hair for five years and I feel
like even if they got some good
information the bad information that's
coming right after that buy them
flubbing up this event right with with
the whole the timing was off just the
rabbit stuff that was going on you
overlooked and a lot of people bypassed
all the stuff that they showed because
they were too busy either dozing off or
saying this is horrible format and stuff
like that last year 2017 the PSX was the
same thing remember what happen every
like all a man is crazy they had just
this was just not the format that's just
what that is and you got to this one
thing didn't this is I've always said
this I think Microsoft really lost this
generation by a huge margin because of
their PR their PR was out there Phil
Spencer
Aaron Greenberg and Mike Ibarra they are
you know Major Nelson
they are the PR team for Xbox where Sony
you never you never see your [ __ ] out
there you never see all those other guys
this executives out there on Front
Street like that at every you know feel
now they make themselves accessible
which is good but it's also a fault they
need to go and hire the top tier they
need to poach some people from Apple
some PR people from Apple or some other
company bring them in and have them to
rebrand what Xbox is and what it needs
to be to make sure that there's no flubs
crackdown I think a lot of air was lit
out the tank when they showed it at that
that was it games coming at that one
event they had all the b-class game have
never played a game in their life now
they got cars humping other cars it was
just a bad so that let the air out for
crack that in DNA went silent for a
whole year and now they've just shown it
so his PR is everything it'll make you a
break you know III hear what you going
on the PR aspect but I want to give
credit to the execs because I feel that
the avars and these guys these guys are
true gamers right these guys really like
I don't I I feel I rather them doing
what they're doing as opposed to the
quote on quote suit who really just
trying to sell you a product but doesn't
really interact or play games like I
like what I like what I like what you're
doing remember when I wanted you to come
to e3 to experience the fan fest and we
was talking about the tickets and stuff
like that yeah yeah
and I really would have loved for you to
come to this eat me so you can actually
add because you were to actually
interact back with the other guys man
really game now I see where you're going
with the PR aspect that maybe it
shouldn't be all on them to have the
tunnel more emotion though I don't know
I don't want them to change because to
me that's what makes Xbox special I
don't want I don't want them to change
but here's the thing the good guys never
get the girl
they can be themselves but when
somebody's out there talking about Xbox
and trying to get these games displayed
and get the hype going they need a whole
nother team that actually is from the
negative publicity
I see now you're gonna have cats going
at fields head errands and all these
guys here and it's unfair to them right
they're just trying to do what they need
to do for their brain and their product
but at the same time if you get a PR
firm to isolate that stuff do you got
other people that can blame if there's a
still a them yeah I feel can walk out
there saying hey guys I'm sorry about
this this event they flub it up you know
they're not good they're not good at
placing the fall guy in front of them
they don't do that kid right
how did your kidded kitty Jess I did
right move on as far as the executives
of what what cradles are saying as far
as they should change and as far as the
PR what's your stance on it I first of
all Microsoft as a whole they don't work
like this anymore and reasons literally
for the opposite reason is because they
were criticized for it back in the day
no the whole Windows 8 thing still today
suffers from a bad PR you know like I
see me when i when i was looking on some
of the sub reddits when like indian
people like oh my god they're gonna make
if they got mobile games like i think
the problem is it's just because there's
this huge corporation with a lot of
baggage they're like you have four years
old 30 years old something like that I
should probably know that but I don't
and how to drag that with them
I think like now you've got like the
windows team and do the whole windows
decide to think working directly with
you
Suzy ass and then work directly and they
don't have a PR between them because in
their mind it's it's better to get raw
sort of information when you don't have
a PR firm watering it down for you in
the middle so it's a double-edged sword
you know yeah it leads to at least to
some clunky announcements maybe and
stuff like that but on the flip side it
should hopefully theoretically lead to a
better product that's more consumer
oriented than you know corporate
oriented maybe it's wrong maybe sorry I
don't know but guys I'm sorry but I
better run
nope Jess oh absolutely I appreciate you
man we love what you and Randy doing so
Lou and thanks again for dropping your
insight and knowledge on the crackdown
topic as well your question is just
absolutely bro have a good woman thank
you Lord chance I got alright kids move
yeah believe yourself could use a better
PR team like yeah I look around you look
at other businesses you look at Apple
you look at Google and you look at even
like PlayStation is just like damn like
why does Microsoft make promoting your
[ __ ] look so difficult so much as it is
Xbox that Microsoft you don't see
anybody coming at Saatchi in the delos a
way when I went out when they market
those surface pro tablets and all that
stuff that's the V on fleek I mean it
was commercials they be sleek they be
nice no point just well it has to be
approached differently because they I
mean the gamer the the gamer in the
gaming community it just we're kind of
entitled what kind of bitching him
you just heard cradles tell you that I
don't care for your ex but everywhere I
don't care that I want my system I want
that premium he said you see what type
of quality you won't get from these
essence I don't want that kind in title
we are entitled the hard core is inter
with them no that was just like some of
the one of the issues I have when it
comes to when them like having to
announce like it was the same thing when
it was coming out with the ex I'm like
man I ain't really going deliver this
wit like nothing like petty stuff and
just by third party schools don't care
if it was for like five months just do
you know I mean just like just thinking
we know we know they didn't have like
any exclusives coming and I just felt
like they could have did a better job
with that so I don't disagree with the
exclusive thing I felt like that could
be really bad if it's not done right
look how the Tomb Raider thing worked
out for them because Square Enix was
stupid but no no that's both of them
like to be honest with you they would
had to delay it out of that year
entirely the whole year was stacked but
you know look at Dead Rising for
regardless what kids movie wants to
think that Games trash like you know
it's it comes to the point where it is
pointless to make something exclusive
unless it's the relevant game like what
are you talking about those games now
yeah a lot of those games are multiplied
now so Frank's we write about that we
need to separate right this is I think a
lot of people misunderstand when people
say Xbox has no games no Xbox has plenty
of games when they're saying that it's
just the games are irrelevant to what is
in the topic in the discussion of the
day right now you know earlier we talked
about God of War right and that game
came out with April May some timeframe
all right on the top 10
like say yeah that that game is going to
be talked about
spider-man's talked about other games
are talked about Xbox don't like Forza
horizon just launched not too long ago
and people are not so it's not even in
the discussion of the day that's what
people are saying
Microsoft needs a game that is the topic
of the day for longer than a week or two
it needs to be a real it needs to make
his mark in in we may have to wait for
Gears 5 for that to happen again but
that's just kind of what it is a
favorite look at the other day we'll
just wrap this thing up because we went
crazy but listen I hear you know
everyone's saying you know we all have
our opinions on the show we do I think
look I think we all in agreement that
the announcements themselves in
themselves were good you may have issues
with the presentation and blasting
everybody just go through real quick or
just your overall rating so kid what was
your overall rating one to ten one to
ten I give it a I give it a solid seven
I said the information I got the
information I wanted I see nothing wrong
with any of the information you got it's
just the show itself is inside Xbox in
the inside Xbox is never like really a
good show was the best right Xbox is
exactly what that kind of information
was designed for Lord Kratos what was
your score 110 hey I give it a 10 out of
10 I told you it was a thing hey hey
I tell you again it wasn't for me this
is what I'm saying on Twitter and in the
YouTube mm-hmm a lot most of the Xbox
guys are enthusiastic about it so
therefore I'll support that it just
wouldn't for me no I'll give it a 10 out
of 10 it did wouldn't I give it a six
out of 10 right at the end of the day I
understand what you know what was going
on I think it would have been a lot
better if obsidian wasn't least I know
just that under way imagine a world
where it never got leaked no one's even
thinking about it and then like we're
buying obsidian it would've blown people
it would have been like the Ninja Theory
a lot of people gave the w2e
three of Microsoft because ninja 30 was
bought love is the same as it's jazzy
love a generous Lord so I'm in the
studio announcements from you were great
two great RPG Studios it's gonna be
interesting to see how they because they
sort of overlap one another in terms of
the type of RPGs that they make so
that's gonna be crazy just to see what
they come up with um crackdown stuff I
enjoy just because they finally got out
in front of it they gave you a release
date that was earlier than wasn't had it
been anticipated so it shows that this
confidence in the product I finally
bring it to the table and the you know
the extra stuff for state of decay for
Forza is cool so information wise I
thought it was there it's just the
presentation I can do it out no doubt
Lord King your score please you know we
are the hardest on ourselves because I
really I told you last week we were
gonna do in a higher score than anyone
else in here I'm gonna give the ten out
of ten as well
everybody said Oh King is smoking crack
or king is or he's dreaming is
everything I said they was gonna do they
did like you saw the crackdown you saw
the destructibility you saw the new
games that they had there you saw the
DLC for the horizon you saw the two
studios that was picked up I said he's
gonna pick up two studio hope they will
pick up five but they picked up - the
show - all right they did these things
and what more do we want like what do
these games have
do to make your just say damn they
trying at least you know you know you
see these I'm sorry
if you Xbox heads see God awards and
spider-man and you're sitting there with
the envious face you don't have to be
envious all you gotta do is get your
bucks up go down to the Xbox games the
studio just purchase quality but they
did a the studios they bought you know I
would say you know composure aren't dead
those are the two wild cards a little
bit I think undeads gonna give a solid
product next I think the bugs really
hurt them yeah a lot of people don't
know this but Microsoft didn't fully
fund their games they are okay yes and
for the next one is gonna be late yeah
if you had a lot of issues but it was
one of the it was a very adult
orientated narrative story and that's
what Microsoft needs I really feel like
besides those two studios because the
ones it's been kind of you know rocky a
little bit the rest I could see give
nothing but eight and fives above like
all that the talent in those studios I
especially obsidian obsidian a ninja
Terry about the making crazy stuff the
look I said they look but I'm still
staying on my six y'all grab that hold
share that whole offices in bushes that
is out of here but listen the announced
what strong just a presentation really
that's if they condensed about an hour
of it it could have been really tight
concise they let other people create
their no exactly so and the end of the
day it's like yo I got I'm gonna be hard
on them look Xbox is my preferred brand
you know I rather give them I'm the
friend that I rather give you the tough
love before you okay okay I get it King
I get it they gave us that many games
in-game pass name them all
but come on man it was actually really
good your pub G you should call this
inside game pass stuff you know what
PlayStation L made 41 million last let's
segue cuz we gotta solve could we can't
no wait fire rapid fire square and PS
now it just get out of it
let's dead the square thing okay wait
there's new PS knocks is the perfect
joint right so listen at the end of the
day I suggest thinness I feel but now
you brought up elephant rule super data
has been released and to my surprise
they talk about games subscription
services generated 273 million quarter
quarter quarter and PlayStation now the
dominant service by generates fifty two
percent of the revenue Oh
Sony is dominant on every gang we just
knew Xbox Live was the top tier it's in
PS PS en is is the top tier we just knew
that game Paz was up there top tier but
no PlayStation now and that shocked even
PlayStation which starts about that
because we as PlayStation guys we all
call PS now dog crap yes we don't use it
we want the native stuff we don't want
the streaming but obviously there's a
lot of PlayStation guys out there that
are in the opposite mine they everything
you know this was thrown and everybody's
TV they had a television let's get it
boogie from you guys there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing wrong
with that subscription thing because it
took me back but also game Pass has not
has the same longevity as PlayStation
now so you built up this team let's
let's look at the same amount of years
let's put that up against up side there
because you thought in your head you
said no game passes be in it I know that
but it wasn't you know why wasn't
because I had a big lead we can't sit
here and start acting like something
that get install base
you can't start acting like this move
boy on the block the new kid on the
block it's gonna knock off the champ the
champ has been running around the ring
for a little bit but he's getting kind
of fat a ranking slow we gonna get the
champ now you said the controllers of
course you're selling more controllers
because your controllers died
all right so okay we're gonna go by that
generation when Xbox had a red ring of
death so and that replace is close to
the 40 million will be told I think
everybody was shot probably Yoshida was
sitting in spit his drink out as a
PlayStation centric guy there was no way
in hell you could tell me that game pass
was not out selling because I mean come
on yes now right there the price
structure the whole streaming thing I
just would not think it but I always
shock when it happened but at the same
time it's like again you know as good as
we want to pretend that all of these
services and stuff is it seems like no
wonder Sony didn't get rid of
PlayStation now like we've been seeing
that nobody using that well no wonder
they keeping it up because I think I
think it wasn't shocking news sheet at
all because I'm think when we look at it
right as gamers we always look at stuff
from our perspective and we think
selfishly that that is just our
perspective step back and say okay who
is this for
right and in doing that it shoutouts
Iran cuz ran ran was on a podcast it
wasn't hit with judge it was another
podcast but he he echoed my sentiments
exactly it's like this isn't for you and
I'm sure the people that PlayStation
know that I'm sure you'll see the new
full well how well free is I was doing
just don't know because we don't care
for it which is crazy because I got a
guy game I would love to see the
percentage increase from when it started
to the point where they allow downloads
I think there's a couple things that the
tribute to I think blood-borne being put
in it helped it I think that's one of
the biggest things is certain Xbox the
PlayStation has going for them is
they're always doing the hundred dollars
off for a year thing revenue is revenue
my xbox game passes behind because well
you're giving it away for one dollar
you're not going to make as much revenue
I have it away for a dollar for long is
a lot of people don't like subscription
they'd rather pay a hundred dollars for
a whole year be good me that's me see
Microsoft I don't know why they don't do
it but if they put a do that they did
with Xbox Live because technically Xbox
Live engage games game path should be
the same price but what's going on here
is they get 50% off if you buy a year of
game of Xbox Live but they don't do with
game pass a whole year for $60 of game
fans it's they're going to probably go
up a million subscribers in a day
because people don't want to pay $18 a
month for a whole year when they could
just may 16 and take a take a half loss
but they're they're getting people on it
for a whole year and chances are how
many people here get the EA access for
$30 a year not paid every month when
that years up how many here forget I got
stuck with an extra month of PS now
because I forgot to
guarantee you a lot of the people
getting these how to do $100 yeah so so
so so you mean to tell me down that
within one month all of a sudden all
these descriptions just went sky-high
and a few times I worked at Dish Network
you'll be surprised how many times I had
to talk to people about cancers of their
Netflix subscription because they forgot
that they forgot it charge card charges
people people forget people okay real
quick can we all agree and can we all
agree with this onei imma give you your
due because I did not expect none of
this I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie
but I got my theories be clear these are
not official numbers super defense the
install base of the PlayStation is crazy
much war ad is well if they had you know
it was in the TVs all that stuff great
game pass is a fairly new service let's
see how this cookies winning I was
surprised I did not expect that I
obviously my opinion is that's the
inferior service but like solver saying
this is not for me you know me and it's
clearly successful for them so that part
I have to revenue that PS now is getting
is double monthly
- is this a slow mo says wasn't that the
quarter when PS now announced you can
download the game so people like alright
let me dust this off when you make it
moves that are directly affecting being
the number one so let's close out man
kid what's your surprise the PS now big
[Music]
alright now that the dust has settled
from exo 18 in European - the inside
Xbox fan fest show live up to the height
promoted by Microsoft a yes tons of
solid announcements and great studio
pickups be no we must demand Microsoft
improve the quality of their shows or C
I don't care
crazy Larry in the white glove segments
always with the show for me when it goes
up later
Lord Dreamcast got Lord says Lord kids
smooth what absolute pleasure to have
y'all in the building bill I know we
lost you cares God cuz its connection it
just only come to very shortly
Lord kid ma'am much appreciated where
could I find people
if you are still they're not dealing
with kids okay he's still there dealing
with kids absolute pressure vent free
back out here in the Twitterverse good
to see you
great to have you back in the realm man
where can I find people sighs definitely
definite you guys can find me on Twitter
at this is good to be back and again I'm
I'm always is such an honor to be
amongst you brothers again everybody hit
that like and subscribe button this is
the premiere show on on the internet
always look out for these brothers
they're doing bigger and better things
and man keeping you guys informed with
the fight and the boxing the games and
everything else in between so much love
myself thank you so much a good happy
that I was fun up I have a laugh so long
a long time you know with me a David get
together all
where you can't appreciate yes I guess I
don't think kid smooth because he's not
here but I'm right here Kratos you know
I want some hashtag he crate aside to
jail on the chat a good show with a
little over than I originally intended
we might have to work on that in the
future but I definitely appreciate
everyone coming by I'm gonna put my
Twitter in the chat I wanted thousand
followers you guys go look it's movement
absolute pleasure bro to have you back
in here I didn't realize it was so long
since you've better idea yeah you said
15 ago you haven't been here now I'm
free I can't can't kiss mu hadn't been
here since Xbox wanna a little bit later
soon I've been like quiet after this
like home move but yeah follow me on
twitter if you want instant stuff for me
but I mean you gotta subscribe to my
channel whatnot which I'm still trying
to break 10,000 subs this is 10,000
I'll give you
wrestling games that make us feel that
way again yeah you guys could found me
fine and find me on Twitter Lord stop
IOP being sovereign on PSN Xbox Live and
you can fire me this week
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I came back to the house I got an
announcement to make real quick
if you get this if we get this likes up
to 150 next week
I give King that picture oh you will
give the pennant
what do you forget what go huh
so I see we got our scholar in the
building s one string team what's up bro
are you are you real quick make this
real quick for everybody I'm gonna be
putting two links in chat right now one
is going to be before the I LPS Super
Smash Brothers
yes Leena the free Oh you here you guys
go make sure you guys get in there click
that link go ahead sign up I'm also
gonna give you guys my giveaway that I'm
impressively so you guys want to get in
that and know it's gonna be for a couple
of months but it's for the division to
yes it's good before the start so
efficient not one not the one above that
but the one above that so if you like
figurines you like cool stuff you like a
lot of stuff that's in there it is legit
I'd videotape everything when I do my
drawing so it is slow-mo attached to
just win and get enough people in there
something to my channel I'm gonna end up
upping it myself to the collectors of
the Phoenix
[Music]
good now this is one also make sure you
guys know we've been rocking a lot of
review so and a lot of streaming from a
bunch of us l-boogie MJ even even once
in a while we get to see you know Lord
addict in there so you know you guys go
hop in there and say hey what's going on
with you know and keep an eye on our
reviews we've been putting a bunch of
them up on the channel hop in there just
got questions what have we got we got
more stuff coming Lord dalabo a lot of
stuff coming we can't get into too deep
but and also a lot dizzy we're working
on some things but stay posted what's
not appreciate you bro thank you for
that information and yeah like you said
like hit the like subscribe make sure
you guys hit them likes you know addicts
gonna do we got the audios gonna come up
from carboxylated tonight the Spotify
iTunes and Google Play
whatever your format we got you also
make sure you check out the IOP channel
5.39 we had a huge guest really bonta's
mark mark Turcotte from Guardian radio
talking about that Activision's earning
call what's going on state a Bungie how
bungees not trying to here it is let
please don't make sure you make sure you
missed that one and of course you know
combat talk King I should be coming
again soon what's the next big one that
is the huge one that's our end-of-year
blowout not one I'm gonna do a little
bit different format because I'm gonna
do a build up throughout the week you're
gonna get our multiple videos going up
to the actual fight to roll it up to the
fight I'm gonna give you a little
speculation which I really don't like to
do because I just like to give you our
core facts and give you betting lines um
but this time I believe that this fight
is gonna be very significant in the
landscape of boxing today um so I I
believe that it needs the proper drum up
and the support that everybody can give
it so I'm please y'all keep supporting
you already know the Royal swag is
moving out here I see how with the
church that's what's up and of course
the patreon is I want more opportunities
you see sob is giving stuff away get in
that patient even if it's the lowest
tier we got higher tiers to that of fun
make sure you guys check it out
everybody got anything else to say or we
out of here
everybody enjoy yesterday out